hey it's evan today i'm answering a
question from one of my youtube viewers
linda love you guys on youtube the
question that came in was do you have
any suggestions for obtaining legal
documents like a consignment agreement
that i could use as a template
and this is like the legal stuff is
something that's really important for
entrepreneurs to figure out we have
to have legal agreements in place i know
it's something that i know for me like i
hate dealing with that stuff it seems
like
the boring work the grunt work the stuff
that i'd rather just focus on growing my
business not
doing all the legal paperwork but it is
important and i know you don't want to
spend a lot of money
hiring lawyers to do it so there are a
couple of resources online that i wanted
to share with you today that could help
so linda in particular is looking for a
consignment agreement the two
websites i want to share are legalzoom
and docstock so legalzoom
it's basically online legal agreements
and everything here is
related to legal agreements and it's
created by lawyers and you can go here
and type in whatever you're looking for
so
let's we want a consignment agreement
there it is and here is a
overview of what a consignment agreement
is it's an example here
uh the cost just for this is 14.95 that
you can buy
so definitely a lot cheaper than having
a lawyer drafted for you from scratch
you can sign up and if you know you need
a lot of legal forms you can sign up and
get an eight dollar munch package or
30 munch package that gives you access
and potentially some support from an
attorney
so that's a great way to start it's
definitely a lot cheaper than going out
and talking to your local lawyer
the other one is doc stock and the same
thing that this is more than just
legal this is any kind of document any
kind of template you can go here and
find an answer for you
so here again if i put in consignment
agreement
so consignment agreement here a whole
bunch of different ones artist gallery
you know if it's specific or not you can
see a lot of different options here
i can click on this one so it's 484
consignment agreement options so you can
see which one
best fits your needs but i can click on
this
i can download it i can print it i can
review it through here
you have a custom browser here that you
can look at the specific details
over what it is and usually to get this
some of them are free some of them are
paid
if you have an account so if i go
download it'll probably ask me to sign
up
you can sign up for free with facebook
or your email account and get access to
it again some of them are free and some
of them are paid
but whatever the cost is if there is
it's a lot cheaper than hiring a lawyer
if you're going to use doc stock or if
you're going to use legalzoom i still
recommend
and if you're using any template i still
always recommend having it run through a
lawyer quickly
afterwards it will cost you some money
for the lawyer to
review your document but it's way
cheaper
to have a lawyer just review your
document and make some changes
than for your lawyer to draft it from
scratch completely
some things to keep in mind is there may
be parts of the
the legal document like a consignment
agreement there may be parts that
that don't apply to your business or
there may be missing things that would
apply to your business that's not in a
standard template
there may be things that are local to
your state or your province
or your country that isn't in the
template so those kind of little details
can be added and just having your lawyer
have a general understanding of what
you're trying to accomplish
they might have a suggestion for a few
extra clauses to include to protect
yourself
in your agreement but it's still way
cheaper to
have your lawyer do that than for them
to draft the whole thing
and it's probably worth the extra
investment to have a lawyer review it
just to make sure you have
all your bases covered because if this
comes back
and you need to go to court you want to
make sure you have ironclad paperwork
and you'll regret not having spent the
you know whatever 100
for the lawyer to review it uh something
to keep in mind those are the two
websites that are definitely worth
checking out hopefully that helped linda
and for those of you watching if you
have
a question let me know leave it in the
comments underneath if you have another
resource to share about how to find
legal documents and templates please
share below if you liked the video give
it a thumbs up and if you have a
question
put in the comments below i'll make a
video response thank you so much and
i'll see you soon
you